hi hi ken
how are you doing oh my goodness i'm so
excited to be talking to you today
yes me too it's so great thank you for
having me
oh quite the opposite you are you being
on this show is such a blessing for us
although i'm doing my research and it
says that we
met before in the hallway of saturday
night live
it was a few years ago when bradley
cooper was hosting and
it was before the hangover came out so
um
and and so i wasn't known and you looked
at me
and said i think i know you i think i've
met you before i know you from somewhere
and i think i had done one movie i think
it was judd apatows knocked up
that had that had come out but uh you
were i just remember you're so nice to
me and i and i was so
shy i was like as no it's my first time
meeting i'm really
big fan no i've met you before i've met
you before
he goes i i i i i have
okay i've met you before you know i was
so shy
i'm shocked i wasn't able to like
because that that's like i never forget
if i see someone in a movie
i'm shocked because i loved you and
knocked up so
much and i'm just you know obviously the
hangover
yes was a big foray into so many of us
meeting you and i think i quote you
pretty much every single day of my life
with the toodaloo
it's i never every day of my kids know
it
we'll just substitute that and we'll
we'll we'll loop it to the load drew
barrymar
or something like that god i do think
it's the best sign-off in cinema history
and now i am so excited to know that i'm
going to be spending new year's eve with
you
it's beyond a dream come true so i i
didn't need for them to ask me
for fox asked me to host a new year's
eve special and uh
i don't know i've never done that before
i've just been i've just been so
grateful
well i mean first of all it's a
no-brainer you're crushing it for fox
you have ken's days you have several
hidden shows
on the network so it's a perfect fit
you know it's smart on them but i never
go out for new year's eve i haven't been
out for
new year's eve and probably almost a
decade and i'm just so excited because i
feel like you and joel mchale who i was
lucky enough to do a movie with
we play ex-husband and wife in blended
with adam sandler
and um so i got the pleasure of working
with him and he's
oh i'm so excited i'm so sorry you had
to work with joel please don't book him
as a guest he's a horrible person
a horrible human being i've worked with
him on community for six years and uh
he was he was the last second get for
the for the new year's eve special it
was more of an act of charity i'm having
joel mckay
well i just say that he's one of my best
friends i just say that
i realized as i'm saying that that we
actually did two projects together we
were in santa clarita diet for several
seasons together
yes we play him and his wife krista are
rival realtors in fact the writers
because i always said realtor
and they wrote this dialogue and for him
that's messing with me saying like i
obviously don't know my business because
i can't even pronounce it the right way
i hear myself going well the realtor
realtor and i i think of joel mchale
so thank you i'll be spending new year's
eve with you and joel and i'm really
looking forward to it because
i i am your audience
so um it is cake week on this show
and your wedding cake
story and i hope to someday see the
picture of it because i have such a
gorgeous one in my mind
that you ordered an ice cream cake for
your wedding cake
yeah yeah my wife got uh she got this
really beautiful
lovely vanilla ice cream cake and it
melted
so the caterer was literally holding
the cake like that so somewhere
you know maybe my wife and i blocked it
out of our minds but somewhere
there's like two hands over that cake
while while my wife and i are like you
know gonna cut like ah
and then somewhere there's a dude with
like two hands around that cake
his hand's fully in the icing and the
ice cream
and it's just dripping down but you know
it's one of those things where
i think those are good luck in many ways
yeah cause eight out
that was that was over 16 years ago
we're still married we still been
together and
uh if you can like go through that and
be
and not have that bump you you know
that's that's a good sign
i know because i think those end up
being like the most delicious
moments in life is like the folly
or the unplanned um
and there's this article that's come out
saying that romance now because of the
pandemic
and the digital space we live in that
love is going back
to a hearkening of a jane austen novel
we now have to have
all of this distance all of this caution
we're rebuilding traditions that have
been
so lost in the swipity swipe swipe swipe
you know era and um
we had a woman on here who said you know
because i was like i love
old traditional dating and it's hard to
do like or
even signals and she goes well if you
want to drop a digital hanky
and i was like that's the greatest thing
i've ever heard because it's
a digital hanky so i'm like
okay digital hank it's not the best
and i was just wondering you've been
married for a long time
do you think that romantic gestures in
the digital age are a possible and be
worthwhile
you know well i'm married so i'm i'm out
of a lot of those equations but
but my but my wife um she liked a post
that i did
and was just it was so sweet because she
doesn't go on social media at all
and you know i said that big emoji with
hearts in the eyes
it was just something funny that i
posted and she did
so i'm in bed with her like the other
night going
oh that's so sweet you like like my po
you know
and it was like dm'd and she she's
almost like uh
she's brand new to social media and
she's like oh no i just she
i don't know just those little kind of
gestures you know
make me love her even more i think i
think that's
it and i think you cap shirt it
perfectly
it's a gesture dropping a digital hanky
is a gesture you're wife harding your
post
is a gesture and in the digital age i
think we
got too far too fast and we lost the art
of gestures
you're so right ken that is what we've
lost
and that is what may we we will regain
this year
the gesture thank you absolutely thank
you
that's so helpful i love that
you